Children with ASD do not follow the patterns that are typical when developing
their social and communication skills. If you recall from our lesson on
development, here we see that these children do not reach the same milestone
markers in the areas of social skills and communication as you typically
develop in children. Some of the symptoms or signs of AS include, making little
eye contact, failing to respond to other people, tending to look and listen
less to people and to their environment, and responding unusually when other
people show signs of anger, distress or affection. Children with ASD seem not
to respond appropriately, as defined by prevailing social norms to emotional
queues and human social interactions. In addition, some children with ASD also
engage repeatitive actions that are termed stereotypy or stereotyped behaviors.
Stereotyped behavior can be defined as persistent mechanical repetition of
speech or movement, or ritualistic movements like hand flapping or rocking. The
number of individuals diagnosed with ASD has increased throughout the years.
And currently rates are approximately 60 per 1,000 births. Why do you think
there has been an increase in the number of children being diagnosed with ASD.
Think about it for a moment and type your response here.